et on commence Véronique par des
parcours à découvrir du côté de manier
le hameaux chose étonnante s'ils sont
comestibles tout à fait alors je vous
emmène prendre l'air et cueillir soit
des baies soit des fleurs soit des
feuilles soit des fruits voilà c'est une
association qui s'appelle manier en
transition qui a fait ça emporter en
arrière avec la ville de
Magny-les-Hameaux et qui vous propose
trois parcours
différents bien sûr avec plusieurs une
longueur différente vous en avez un qui
est de 3 km qui s'appelle la boucle
urbaine qui est accessible à tout le
monde même si on est à mobilité réduite
vous en avez un autre qui s'appelle la
boucle de la vallée qui qui a 10 km et
la boucle des hameaux qui lui fait 14 km
alors c'est entretenu par les jardiniers
municipaux de Magny-les-Hameaux en fait
autrefois il y avait déjà il y avait des
beaucoup de poiriers beaucoup de
pommiers et la population se servait que
hier faisait même du site etc donc ils
sont un peu voulu retrouver cette idée
là donc ils planter une 150 arbres et
150 arbustes fruitiers voilà et c'est
complètement gratuit et ce sont des
parcours qu'on fait donc voilà seul il y
a des panneaux pédagogiques en revanche
qui vous explique quand il y a les
choses quoi en faire etc alors sortie
aussi éducation parce qu'on peut
apprendre et vous pensez on vous fera
remarquer remarquer on vous fera
découvrir des arbres remarquables sur un
des parcours aussi voilà c'est un
patrimoine à la fois naturel et culturel
parce qu'il y a aussi des des
lieux particuliers enfin des lieux à
découvrir voilà alors par exemple sachez
qu'en ce moment c'est bien de cueillir
les orties parce qu'elles ont leur plus
haute teneurs en fer et alors du coup
vous allez parce que c'est pas le tout
cueillir des orties des fleurs d'acacia
ou des fleurs de pissenlit il faut
savoir quoi en faire et il vous donne
des recettes alors moi je les ai vu sur
le site peut-être que c'est sur les
panneaux j'en sais rien mais c'est
facile retrouver leur un pesto d'ortie
par exemple facile
et mentale vous qui aimez l'Italie je
vous recommande une panacota à la fleur
d'acacia très facile à faire la panna
cotta il faut le savoir et quelque chose
encore plus drôle rigolo c'est un
comment ça s'appelle pardon j'arrive une
fricassée de pédoncule de pissenlit donc
voyez le pissenlit jaune bon après ils
sont plus jaunes il y a des petites
chandelles qu'on s'amuse à souffler vous
faites ça vous aussi
je le fais plus mais ça m'est déjà
arrivé parce que ça se mange pas ça donc
vous soufflez bien sur vos fleurs après
vous éliminez les capitules les
capitules sont les boutons des des
pissenlits et après vous faites votre
votre fricassée enfin tout est bien
expliqué voilà donc on peut découvrir
plein de choses plein de choses et aussi
des des recettes gustatives les déguster
on nous parlons vous nous faites
découvrir je vais y arriver pardon à
Véronique du yoga mais du yoga original
puisqu'il est à pratiquer avec des chats
s'appelle le catch yoga voilà alors le
yoga c'est tendance le catch yoga ou le
pet yoga c'est encore plus tendance ça
vient de sortir apparemment ça vient des
États-Unis donc là ça s'est passé à
Maurepas dans le sang aquatique
castellia il y a eu deux séances de yoga
avec en présence de 10 chatons alors
c'est un initiative aussi d'une
association l'association sauvetage et
chats en détresse qui a une antenne en
Île-de-France et l'idée c'était aussi de
que ça fasse levier pour que les gens
aient envie d'adopter un chat
éventuellement mais pas que ça c'est
aussi ça fait penser à la remontée un
chat qui vient se poser sur vous quand
vous êtes en pleine méditation etc ça
aide à la relaxation ça apaise et aux
Etats-Unis il y a même des gens qui le
font avec des chats des chèvres naines
des lapins enfin un animal de compagnie
quoi
au centre aquatique Castalia
sessions de katyoga du côté de Maurepas
et on va terminer en forêt de
Rambouillet où les fonds sont très
vulnérables puisqu'en ce moment c'est la
période des naissances
alors là c'est la période des naissances
comme vous dites alors ce qu'il faut
faire c'est surtout si vous envoyez si
vous en croisez un enfant caché dans les
herbes il faut surtout pas s'en
approcher même si la mère est pas là ça
veut pas dire qu'il a abandonné au
contraire elle est partie la chevrette
est partie se nourrir pour pouvoir
allaiter son bébé parce qu'elle a besoin
de reconstituer ses forces il se peut
aussi qu'elle ait eu deux fonds et les
naissances en fait se font pas coup sur
coup il y a plusieurs heures
d'intervalle entre la naissance du
premier du second fond et elle elle est
elle accouche pas au même endroit je
pense que c'est l'idée c'est de pas
mettre tous ses œufs dans le même panier
donc bah elle est entre les deux quand
elle en a deux donc voilà on peut croire
que que le fond est abandonné par sa
maman et pas du tout il faut surtout pas
toucher et surtout sur tout tenir ses
chances son chien en laisse car pareil
l'odeur du chien après la chevrette ne
s'occupe plus du bébé qui est
extrêmement vulnérable pendant un mois
et même jusqu'à 6 mois et puis le chien
peut blesser aussi le fond et donc voilà
voilà
surtout surtout pas y toucher merci
Véronique et je le disais on vous
retrouve aussi très régulièrement la
présentation de Vy P veri Yvelines qui
mettent en lumière les personnalités du
département qui sont vos prochains
invités
voilà alors j'ai invité Mathieu Davignac
et directeur de recherche au château de
Versailles c'est un historien auteur et
qui est aussi conseillé pour le cinéma
assez souvent d'ailleurs et là il vient
de sortir un livre qui s'appelle le
plaisir de vivre ou les libertés de la
marquise de Joco chez Talandier et c'est
une histoire d'une jeune femme très
libre qui qui se marie qui divorce qui
est un enfant naturel qui épouse son
amant c'était aussi la maîtresse de
Talleyrand et c'est une période un peu
un peu charnière juste après la
Révolution et il y a plein de libertés
qui apprennent malheureusement
seront supprimés mais elle en a profité
et elle a bien fait voilà et deuxième
émission c'était avec Eric Janssen qui
est le coteur de très cher baron de
Rothschild avec Nadine de Rothschild la
fameuse baronne elle relate la vie de 12
baronnes de Rothschild voilà et des
femmes assez incroyables une à la
passion des bateaux de course l'autre
consacre la vie à l'étude des puces et
donc des Vy P à retrouver dès à présent
disponible sur Youtube vous avez aussi
sur TV 78.com pour retrouver vyb bien
sûr votre émission sur TV 78 on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour de nouveaux insolites merci merci à
vous on va
on va tester d'ici là